en busca de artículos de primera
necesidad tras semanas de bombardeos
rusos los civiles atrapados en mariupol
a menudo tienen que caminar kilómetros
para encontrar comida tras regalos es
difícil pero qué podemos hacer
se han pedido la entrada a la ayuda
humanitaria lo que ha dejado a los
civiles hambrientos sin comida agua ni
combustible en los últimos días los
separatistas y las fuerzas respaldadas
por rusia que controlan este barrio han
distribuido ayuda humanitaria a los
civiles como en este parqueadero los
residentes se esfuerzan por comprender
el horror que se ha infringido en sus
hogares a dónde podemos ir tenemos miedo
se imaginan tratar de vivir y luego
caminar sobre cadáveres caminando sobre
cuerpos que no han sido enterrados
durante 15 días a pesar de los llamados
al alto el fuego en mariupol para que
los civiles puedan salir por los
corredores humanitarios la guerra sobre
el terreno continúan los combates
persisten en la ciudad donde
recientemente se han cavado fosas para
los muertos
esta era una abuela de suiza adelante
roma
se están llevando a cabo nuevos
esfuerzos para evacuar a los que siguen
atrapados en la ciudad el jueves la vice
primera ministra de ucrania dijo que un
convoy de 45 autobuses estaba en camino
para ayudar a los civiles a escapar por
la ruta propuesta a través del puerto de
perdidas que controlado por rusia la
agencia de las naciones unidas para los
refugiados y la cruz roja buscan
facilitar el paso seguro desde mariupol
la evacuación estaba prevista
inicialmente para el jueves pero la cruz
roja intentará liderar la operación este
viernes son los que siguen en mariupol
se están quedando sin acceso a los
alimentos sin agua sin ayuda humanitaria
por lo que es realmente importante que
esta operación pueda llevarse a cabo
según lo previsto
la única condición para que la
evacuación se lleve a cabo es que todas
las partes respeten el alto el fuego